[Music]
foreign
[Music]
crime daily our final segment brings us
to a New York courtroom where actor
Kevin Spacey is on the stand as the
first witness for the defense all to
battle an accusation of sexual
misconduct spanning back decades actor
Anthony Rapp is suing Spacey for
millions of dollars in Damages accusing
the award-winning actor of inviting him
to his Manhattan home bringing him to
bed and inappropriately touching him
when rap was just 14 years old on Monday
court reporters described Spacey as
quote emotional during his testimony as
he denied the allegations against him
Spacey also said he regrets releasing a
public apology back in 2017 when rap's
accusations came out claiming his
publicity team pushed him to do it in
spite of him being innocent on Tuesday's
space he was cross-examined by Rob's
Attorney Richard steigman on the same
issue pointing out fallacies in the
draft apology statement Spacey again
throwing his PR team under the bus
name of Spacey's attorneys were able to
dismiss the claim of intentional
infliction of emotional distress because
it was duplicative of another claim what
exactly does that mean and how big or
small a win was this for Spacey
not a big win but we're going back to
law school you know our first year civil
procedure this is a federal case but
because of that diversity case
substantive New York law applies and
under New York law if the battery claim
and the intentional infliction of
emotional distress claim are based out
of the same conduct they're duplicative
in the intentional Affliction claim
needs to be dismissed so the battery
claim is there and you can obviously get
emotional distress damages for sexual
batteries so not much of a win for Kevin
Spacey here we'll see how that case
continues Terry what do you think space
of Spacey speaking about his father's
history as a Neo-Nazi and white
supremacy did this help his case
you know Brian I don't think it will
help his case but it's not going to hurt
his case either I mean what he's trying
to do is throw out a whole bunch of
excuses basically for why he is who he
is he claims he did not come out as
being gay because his father was this
racist and a homophobic and he held
these anti-semitic views and ultimately
he is claiming that he was afraid of his
father apparently at one time when he
told his father he wanted to be an actor
his father literally cursed him out so
he basically is trying to say I had a
very difficult childhood he claims they
moved around a lot and that was very
difficult for him as well he said his
father really was abusive and it was a
complicated family Dynamic and I
definitely think he is throwing everyone
under the bus including his father and
it seems to me that his PR team is also
under the bus where we'll see how the
jury responds to this as it can as this
case continues thank you for joining us
here on Long crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss Justice in
America